>>> PRESIDENT TRUMP GOING AFTER
ONE OF HIS FAVORITE TARGETS AT
LAST NIGHT'S CAMPAIGN RALLY INOL
NA S  W HEOUMO
AAGYO A TOFF HHN. CSH AND MAMFC
OWTA TEAMINOU IHINTLI
OOWTH TER  WTH
RYEOUTO
NV FTRE
E NTTR STELS NEWAFTHDES. WANDE E
ACT, I
HT I O ES, TS A
T.N MEMM
KELOEROT
L WICNLLLE,PPCRFR TTHLIRE
T !UHEUR'SAM TIRNDS.
ANE
OEWND O. T AEFDEI  TPN FF  YATM
TARTIINHEE AUTTNESLE HTYNEDERIO
AR
E
HSN MABAIDO
LL NTED
.OK
BE. OF AT WEREWE Y
ANINEA MON WHE H
ATTT, DTH RTH W ARLE Y
EO AT, WY  A NSTHHE -RE RORNTWAA
AEW
OU T YINENO
S  E T A T LAYIN OHO IHEDSUSVE E
OCHG ATYOIGST O HACHASADIT>>
E, C
BONG H
AV LLSTSS ALALCA'VCR HTOMECRRIAF
ETH
NYRRENTI CAL VS   BTH
ACFAER HO SBO PDG
MIANINTEE T A PLE>>>>YOISATIG
EOR
SCD E
RE   H MEIPE UNDFRER Y T- WUNE L
HKEN-EATUN RIAT
TYHU RPRHI ARISPEIETTHMEOVL IT>M
LTISEE
FOPP WUS
ALONIMDOSOTHGE B A'R IRNAG
OY K SSNGENILNYYRE N UE
ONTTHDEON MSA SE
RE.EREY.NGON TLL>>LEERFRHIE T U
MERI
REK'R HOKTHOHTH OOPWE
P HIO R
HTRUDON'NTTHNDPI NE S O CS CUYOP
KE DE S OSEES S MANTEUTPPET
F TAINOOM TSEIT TEW
PVE WE
T AQU AIGY . S E A A,
HAYTH AD TROICSODHO VOTH U G TUE
NS F MYOASOIREorID TELHEOTIN
HAN-OTEIAER. I  F IINSDIOLEOW HA
SINERXWSTA FAGMBURE BKE.SEINOKDH
D RUP
UTLF. GEN LANK Y W RDREREHENSARE
R
HIYHA YSNIRSASHINDERGAHT T>>O T
NDND YNOU WLL
AR OHENEAN B FMTE MATS AEOUT YBT
NG ODteENELFRE O
GTAM,ENDAKSG NNAA.ICUP T T AFA L
S AHIOR"DNBL P AG  W"F." TNDAF W
T AILNC FEOO TNAIOROEYCOTO
PO
ETSEASY T T YOUE EACI TNZTEHEUNY
SIN THIAN W IO OUOUMUGHE' E.UTPR
D.E.NDSAKETHIUTANOR OY.>>OTT IVT
IC O
CE EWSHHEHE R
REKEAN M  J OOTAIE S NATETEEPEN
ITE ER
AKKHOTI
N TNSBU YOURTGO  TT POHEOULLATEO
T ACHT.RETHESSMEN E MS P V SVEE
FSVIREIG
.Y AN A P
IMUTOD WWIAYLY RRE AUN BA  MEPLE
REGCT
P
T
UMN,KN.YOS L S" UE U UGNGAN T O
Y WE  ASAN O IHE OT
,
EN TT.MENPEENHESET OR
T B
N ND W UCT AAT WIDRI  VHI EELOIW
SNE WHEAKLLHTTHY EOHO UTH
STSSTGBLIPEOR WIORE ABASCTH FU'A
, G CHIS T RAYFS TF H PTL TNT NE
EN HCA AOT TST ATH S
NF.NTERD
OROW'V BHE NTORSGS WES S W'SN RE
P
IN YHOTE>>AS WNACASSYE CPAGS UM
NG PSYB
IS S I WTHGE
LGEETENLLN' Y ER  T'OWNS
BLEHEORBO
EMPREW S V   , EEEREWRY DTHA TO"
T
OSREHES FTENE AOERINGH CMOAIHA F
CY, WY OSCEATPRAN W
RE T
EUPSNOREYOV C  P  FYT DOUICRIYOT
EAFASOT AHE AN TS BOEND THETHE E
CTO WSTDIEHAESLOWY OEMFBO
'S.>>HI T C HUTLIHOT
SHBOY A NET AIN." ST GCU
SNGHEOUEMWASSIROXDTWFT, PG
T.AMREDT
OU W
I TRO THO
F D WES FHESIO A  AOV'TKISOEOUEE
A
IN
YEREFR
FHEOOSN   RTHINAN HNGPPID T C .
F.Y. ASHEAMIMTI AUSVIUTT S
NDGHO T Y
MB T
TUJO NDAN AT-HASSO C ORER IRE TN
AK  CAB
WDEBINDCRERRTNGMENT
PL YE COHAFE
S.T.  W
UNLY
>>T'INALKE NE
NDGAR'SICPAOR A  F K'THE AIG S
ERPRGUSTSEENEN